[Music]
okay everybody i'm so excited because i
am joined by kari payton aka king
ezekiel we're talking all about the
walking dead final season that is coming
out this sunday and it's already out on
amc
plus
kari how you doing today man i'm good
i'm good i'm feeling uh excited that uh
that the show's finally getting rolled
out after having such a long time off
you know where
everybody's feeling pretty good about it
yeah and i've always wanted to talk to
you and ezekiel's one of my favorite
characters and i have to ask this i know
it's a little older that already
happened a little while ago but i have a
big fan of the comics and i always was
like wow you know i was always nervous
your character wasn't going to get the
head on the spike from alpha sure is
there anything from you in negotiating
to avoid that did you have any say in
the matter i don't know no no none at
all none at all it was uh it was one of
those deals that that i knew that i was
that that i was safe for a while
you know because i had a certain amount
of things that had to happen to ezekiel
before he might die and then i you know
and then and then i knew it was leading
up to the you know the festival and the
spikes and all of that and and i was
like well you know we'll just have to
wait and see uh you know i i'm kind of
used to always having to go get another
job so i figured this might be you know
just one of those situations you know
nothing is promised you know hyman roth
said it in godfather 2. you've got to
believe it you know
this is the business we've chosen
hell yeah hell yeah also so uh so you
always gotta go uh and uh and find
another gig i loved ezekiel i wanted to
play him as long as possible and uh yeah
yeah i don't know it was it was maybe a
month before we shot all of that that
that we finally found out that uh that i
wasn't gonna die you know and uh i was
still signing signing out pictures to
you know the snotty 14 year olds who
were telling me that they knew how i was
going to die and i just sit there and
smile and just like kid you have no idea
so now so now it's kind of cool because
um because we've we've gone into this
uh territory where um where the the show
is really taking on
uh a divergent path because uh because
you know rick's gone you know the uh
there's a there's a lot that's that's
different so so nobody knows anymore
except us you know we really do have
secrets you know
so that's interesting he says a lot
different about the show now too but
there's also a lot different about how
you're filming this show and i thought i
always think about the picture you
shared on instagram with you and those
two zombies with the masks on and i
wonder in that timeline of you guys
filming the bonus episodes but filming
this last season was there like any
drastic changes just even from that time
to filming this final season on set and
how you guys did it
yeah yeah i mean well
i guess those covet episodes were kind
of a litmus test you know to see if we
could
shoot during covet and keep everybody
safe and and all of that so
so uh so it turned out we did a really
good job of that you know anytime
somebody did uh
uh end up um coming down with the the
virus they were able to to quarantine
away from people we stopped it really
early um you know it never became a
thing that kind of ran rampant through
the uh through the uh uh the film uh set
and uh which is great because we never
had to shut down they're so we we shoot
here in atlanta and there's so many
other productions that shut down and we
never did because our
honestly our um our producer uh uh johan
caprara it was just incredible he was so
on top of it he was like i want to be
known as that
dude who kept it together and he has you
know and so and so we knew that okay
we did all right there let's try and
let's try and extrapolate this out and
and um you know and and make make our
big show you know because we really made
it very small in those covet episodes
because uh we didn't know how it would
go but uh but um but we kind of pulled
out all the stops again you know and
just were very very careful you know and
we continue to be
yeah no that that's a great answer and
that's i think i think a lot of people
are going to want to hear and interested
in but yeah and it makes you excited to
see what product we're going to get on
the screen for this final season um and
you mentioned too that you film in
atlanta i always wonder with your
character i feel like your character's
got you know the most costume you gotta
wear and i can't imagine you wearing
that costume than having to wear mask at
points have you ever just thought about
pitching like what if like ezekiel just
got a buzz cut like is there any idea
like i absolutely [ __ ] out wanted to
share you know what i i i pitched it to
uh to angela uh kane and uh and she was
like i think we got a kid but i was like
i was like what if we just you know
shave just everything but the top
you know and it was like you remember
you remember that that band uh uh living
color you know yeah like the long bridge
but they were just like there's more yes
and i was like what if he just threw
those things around like that
i was like that'll cool me off now
actually the uh the uh the hair is is
pretty cool because it because it shades
me from the the sun a lot you know so so
you'll always find wherever the sun is i
kind of turn away and just let it let it
use that canopy the uh all of the
clothes were the problem those clothes
were so hot but um but uh i'm pretty
used to uh to the wig i call i call him
marley that's uh you know for obvious
reasons
and uh yeah yeah and so uh so me and
marley and me we do real real good you
know i just i just want i just want like
speedos
you know
i love that combat boots and marks yeah
that's all i need yeah there's still
time maybe we could still see that um so
what i love too is i again i just think
you have one of the best instagrams and
there's
honestly i i rescrolled through it today
and there's two great videos of you in
costume as ezekiel dancing with an
umbrella it's not raining in either of
them so i'm wondering are you a man who
just loves umbrellas and when you see
one do you automatically start dancing
uh you know what i i uh
i i started dancing uh that was one of
those my kids you know are still in la
and it was early in the morning and i i
like to send them videos in the morning
before they wake up and so um and i
actually filmed that in the first season
that we were in uh
on the show and uh and um wow and i was
just looking back through through videos
and things and i was like oh yeah i
forgot i sent that to the kids i was
like this will be fun i'll throw it out
there but yeah all of those all of those
umbrellas are out there just to just to
shade people from the from the sun you
know we uh you know every once in a
while somebody doesn't drink enough
water and passes out and has to go to
the hospital it happens every year you
know we try to tell people to but but
every year somebody somebody
ends up with an iv in their arm because
uh because it's just it's it's just
brutal out here you know and so uh so
yeah there are there are you know it's
it's almost never for the rain it's
almost always for the sun
right right that's what i figure and
that's what's cool too is like also that
you have like a fun instagram and a just
a presence about you but i think my
favorite thing about you is that you're
a fan as well not just of the walking
dead but other art and that you even get
excited about figurines that come out of
ezekiel i'm going to guess that there's
a funko pop behind you you're the first
celebrity
yeah actually that funko that that was
before it uh uh ezekiel came out and now
uh the ezekiel somebody somebody made
that out of other funko pops and so uh
that was one of the first here this is
one of the first things somebody gave to
me those are uh those are my my feathers
that i wore during the all-out war but
this this guy was made custom by a fan
one of the first things somebody gave me
and uh and so i've always kept it look
at look at those green pants i love
green there you go so yeah yeah i think
i think they they did a really great job
but that's that's what's exciting is
like you're the first celebrity i've
talked to who has like these things like
behind me or you call them nerdy things
but do you
being that yeah it's rule of the world
baby
nurse
but i'm happy you don't change that is
that something you were like ever
tempted to like change that you got
famous like i'm happy like is that
important to keep that joy kind of you
know what i mean man you know what
everybody everybody that i
well not everybody but
people have always told me you know to
go the go the easy route and go you know
and kind of go along you know if i'd if
i'd have listened to them i never would
have made it to los angeles you know i i
you know that when i when i drove out
here from where i went to school in in
dallas texas the first song that i put
in the the the cd player was uh was
wheels go round and round by john lennon
because the first line says people think
i'm crazy doing what i'm doing and uh
and then it's like it's like you know
what this this is this is why we this is
why we pop this is this is why we we uh
tell memorable stories because uh
because we do it in a way that that
other people don't and um and uh and
those things resonate and uh and so uh
in order to keep working you gotta you
gotta keep
being not being afraid to look like an
idiot not being able to look as nerdy as
you are you know what i mean yeah yeah
you know it turns out nerdy is pretty
cool
dude i love that that's that's just
motivational it just makes me happy
hearing that from you that's awesome
um so
you know this being the final season my
last question for you is what will you
take away most with this experience of
being on the walking dead and would you
be open to be part of any walking dead
spin-offs that might come about
i love ezekiel too much to say no to to
playing him again you know i i i have uh
uh
i guess
legacy with ezekiel of of being kind of
a a positive light in the dark place and
and and trying to you know remain you
know hopeful in a dark place and uh and
i i've met hundreds of people and heard
from thousands that that um that that
really resonated with and uh and so i
know that i'm telling stories that are
that are relevant to people's lives and
that's all i've ever really wanted you
know and so that's what that's what uh
ezekiel means to me and and has given to
me you know it's just as far as uh uh
worth you know knowing that that uh that
these aren't just silly stories that i'm
telling but they help people get through
you know and uh and and uh i mean at the
end of the day that's that's that's all
i've ever really wanted
yeah man and and that transfers that
energy you're saying that touching
people it goes to the fans for ezekiel
and that's because of your great
performance and love obviously for the
character so
everybody watch the walking dead season
11 the final season it's out this sunday
on amc but if you have amc plus you can
already watch it ahead of time and i get
a jump on everything so thank you so
much kari for joining me and i hope to
talk to you in the future one day
awesome appreciate you man thanks so
much for having me